mesdames et messieurs chers auditoire il
nous est facilement admissible que la
société puisse avoir une influence sur
notre vie notre consommation
nos préférences culturelles en sont de
parfaits exemples
mais saviez vous que la société trouve
même son mot à dire sur notre manière
intime de gérer un drame faiblesse et
déshonneur serait ainsi la réaction
conventionnelles qu'elle nous impose car
malheureusement oui il existe un diktat
inconscient celui de complaisance dans
la douleur où chaque individu est poussé
à exploiter son drame vécu comme excuse
venant justifier son inaction
je m'appelle nadia la jude
j'ai 20 ans et il y a deux ans et trois
mois dans les intempéries qui ont touché
la côte d'azur
j'ai perdu ma grande soeur alors très
vite ce décès a été perçu par autrui
comme étant un frein qui devait si ce
n'est me stopper du moineau ralentir
quelque peu
car après tout qu'est ce que la société
pouvait bien attendre de moi rien
certains me voyais déjà abandonné mes
études
d'autres m'ont conseillé de faire une
pause de reculer pour en quelque sorte
mieux sauter par la suite mais à cette
idée reçue que l'on essayé de me
déguiser en choix personnel j opposé un
mécanisme psychologique
encore peu connu en france la résilience
d'où la capacité qu'ont développé
certaines personnes pour traverser
l'adversité en tirant d'un fléau
apparent le meilleur des conséquences
j'ai donc décidé de prendre ma douleur
et de la transformer en quelque chose de
positif pour moi mais également pour
autrui
j'avais conscience mesdames et messieurs
que je pouvait agir et plus que tout je
refusais d'attendre la vie est courte
j'en avais eu la preuve il fallait donc
une idée un projet un objectif vers
lequel convergent et c'est la raison
pour laquelle un mois après son décès
j'ai décidé d'entamer une action
humanitaire en sa mémoire
le projet yasmina il visait en la
construction d'un puits dans une ville
d'à jane d'airé à 400 kilomètres au nord
du togo et en l'acheminement progressive
d'une collecte qui permettait de
satisfaire à des besoins de première
nécessité
je ne savais pas encore mais je faisais
preuve de résilience c'est à dire que
j'avançais dans cette difficulté qui me
frappait et me positionner là où
personne ne m'attendait je n'avais en
tête qu'un seul mantra c'était de
transformer cette obscurité autour de
moi en lumière éclatante
si je devais schématiser la résilience
jeu-là diviserait certainement en trois
étapes la première serait l'acceptation
de la réalité un livre que j'ai lu m'a
ici beaucoup aidé le manuel d'epictète
la sagesse stoïcienne qui en est tiré
préconise un cheminement progressif vers
le bonheur avec une distinction
fondamentale
il ya d'une part les éléments qui nous
sont intérieures ce sont nos pensées nos
choix nos actions
vu qu'ils nous sont intrinsèquement liés
vous en conviendrez que nous pouvons les
contrôler al'inverse se trouvent des
événements extérieurs qui nous arrive à
un instant t
avec plus ou moins d'impact sur notre
vie ne faisant partie ni de notre
psychisme ni de notre corps on ne peut
donc les contrôles et les wc sont des
situations de crise qui font partie de
ce deuxième type d'événement dans
lesquels il faut commencer
progressivement à renverser ce rapport
de victimisation
d'autant plus que dans cette salle
chacun a au moins une fois et est
confronté à la difficulté
saviez-vous qu'en moyenne une personne
sur deux est amené à vivre un
traumatisme dans sa vie une personne sur
deux si l'on prend comme échantillon cet
auditorium
cela reviendrait à ce que chacun en se
tournant vers son voisin de gauche
il verrait un individu qui portent des
fardeaux dont il faut d'ailleurs retiré
la connotation négative car comme l'a si
justement dit confucius nul pierre ne
peut être poli sans friction alors nulle
âme ne peut pas re perd son existence
sans expérience
il est important de comprendre que
l'adversité n'est pas une exception et
qu'elle finira par tous nous toucher un
jour donc certes il faut l'accepter mais
commençait à voir en elle une
opportunité pour développer tout son
potentiel
la deuxième étape sera la transformation
le retournement où je commence à agir
sur ce que je maîtrise
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
entamé ce projet en un court laps de
temps de dix mois alors assurément oui
j'ai rencontré des difficultés
et mme est la première à laquelle j'ai
dû faire face a justement été ce diktat
inconscient d'oisiveté de l'homme face à
la douleur mais le plus important ici
n'a jamais été ce cotre y penser
ce qui a été déterminant est fondamental
c'est que pour la première fois j'avais
confiance
je croyais en moi et plus que tout je
croyais en ce projet de l'eau la
satisfaction de l'un des besoins les
plus primaires qui soit et qui en plus
aller constitué ma réponse insolente
face à la mort car quand on y réfléchit
l'eau et ce qui a pris la vie de ma
grande soeur mais d'un autre côté l'eau
et ce qui a permis à des centaines de
femmes et d'hommes togolais d'être sauvé
c'est la preuve que d'un même événement
en adoptant un nouvel angle d'aproz tout
se modifie ce qui vous apparaissait
comme un fléau devient alors votre
carburant ce qui est à la base même de
la résilience la troisième étape sera
l'action et la convergence de tous nos
efforts vers cet objectif final le mien
il est vrai était humanitaire mais il
n'est pas fixe vous aussi vous pouvez en
trouver un
selon vos centres d'intérêts être porté
par une idées inspirantes quelque chose
qui vous pousse à bondir du lit chaque
matin et ce même si le monde autour de
vous s'écroulent ou est amené à
s'écrouler
ne laissez jamais une seule mauvaise
passe
définir le reste de votre vie et des
jouets vos ambitions premières
regardez moi mesdames et messieurs nadia
20 ans
quasi titulaire d'une licence de droit
public j'avoue avoir encore du mal à
fermer lessive et pourtant j'ai réussi à
faire preuve de résilience donc vous
aussi vous en être capable
d'autant plus que ce concept vous
amènera là où personne ne vous attend le
23 juillet 2016 aurait été le 32e
anniversaire de ma grande soeur alors
une idée reçue aurait voulu que ce soit
un jour des plus tristes et pourtant
j'en garde un des meilleurs souvenirs de
ma vie car en cette date je ne me trouve
et non pas chez moi mais à des milliers
de kilomètres au coeur de la savane
togolaise en train d'inaugurer le puits
la source
yasmina donc modestement oui on peut
dire que j'ai apportée à ce peuple mais
je peux vous garantir que j'ai reçu bien
plus la résilience va opérer en nous un
éveil envers cette idée reçue que l'on
nous véhicules depuis tout petit où tout
va bien dans la vie c'est faux mesdames
et messieurs tout ne va pas bien au
contraire
la vie est une succession d'étapes plus
ou moins difficiles mais vous savez quoi
aucune n'est insurmontable dans cette
salle on représente un échantillon de
l'humanité et chacun d'entre nous est un
potentiel en puissance
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
conclurai mon propos en vous citant un
proverbe de sagesse chinoise trouvé je
lave ou au détour d'un film disney celui
ci affirme ainsi qu importe que le vent
hurle la montagne jamais ne ploie devant
lui qu'importe que le vent hurle la
montagne jamais ne ploie devant lui je
vous inviterai donc à faire preuve de
l'ensemble de la force et de l'honneur
que
possède la montagne face à cette vie qui
peut hurler devant vous merci
[Applaudissements]